Game one of how many I don't know all
right hmm all right let's go with this
why not support that Center let's go
with this too symmetrical so far we're
going to have a trash that's what we
have all right let's take here right now
since that Bishop already moved gotta
watch out for the d5 break we're going
to do a four they are okay let me take
here and let's get to this square
there's no there's no keeping my night
out of d5 now um what else what should I
be planning I could do b6 Bishop d7
wears it better to just do a Bishop d7
here I think I like b6 and then Bishop
here maybe I should do that right away
let's go get that bishop on the diagonal
I'm to moes away from castling something
that does have some of my concern also
what has my concern is this pressure
bishops hitting it logical move the rook
is going to be on this half over file is
this not going to be getting excited
about g5 and hitting both of these I
need more development let's break the
pin not what given the time I think I'm
going to be doing okay if I have control
over d5 these next few moves are going
to be what
the next few moves are going to let me
know what the scoop is on the position
as you're checking some things out let's
castle and I don't have a good reason
not to play here so let's play here I
think I stand better I have control over
this over this d 5 square so purposeful
moves will include rook c8 to have a
good reason not to do that right now for
a second I was thinking maybe there's a
way to target this guy actually you know
what instead of rook c8 maybe I should
start to address the pressure white
might have against this structure with
sacking on f7 maybe and following up
with Bishop takes on e6 how do you
address that pressure I think by playing
here my computer is going a little crazy
or unusual
my laptop I should probably get
something other than the laptop to do
these streams this is pretty intensive
here okay well let's go I don't have a
reason not to do that I have to be a
little bit concerned about h 7 i'd like
to trade some minor pieces that'd be
nice if queen e to what do i do about
the pressure against this pond i really
don't want to move it whoa i think i'm
going to be uh what's the scoop here I
take the bishop has to take here first I
think I'm going to have a perfect
position where I mean by that what I
really mean to say I am well we're
welcoming apparently we're gonna be
having exchanges here um Knight takes
Knight is my first thought Bishop takes
bishop is needed otherwise I take care
knight takes Bishop takes Queen takes
Queen takes Knight and then just like
Knight f6 and then queen before I think
my knight on f6 will end up defending
everything let's do that I'm going to
shoot in right here to be for my
cleaning I have this protector with my
bishop an important detail let's get
this clean out of there my nights around
to watch over this point and I think I
could be very disruptive with the Queen
move here next hitting the pond I'm also
hitting at g2 once so maybe some
variations I could have my queen
converge on that point as well I have to
be concerned about a rook up and over
mmm
I was just thinking about move my knight
here haha oh let's not do that let's not
move that night pressure against this
guy Queen here rookie three Queen takes
pawn I'm on the ruck threatening mate
and stuff I think that's the right idea
why am I waiting so long to do it I
don't have answers to those questions
this pond is also in a pin don't you
dare move pawn this has to be
inconvenient I want to move my rook to
just so like in some cases maybe if the
Queen does capture here my king could
run for the hills fa e 7 hill runner
variation what do you do now you have to
defend this it's got to be very awkward
this is a weak point earlier it was my
night that made use of it I guess a
queen being placed here as well it's
pretty good B to D for right here I
could take here I'm hitting the brook
and night back rank issues my King might
need to run for the hills Queen takes
here hmm
Bishop takes Knight takes rook here i'm
good i have me I don't know I'm gonna do
it oh man but wait now I could just take
this night and I'm defending stuff
laterally I'm just going to take this
[ __ ] up if the replace here or
something maybe I don't need to maybe I
could just play here whoa whoa whoa hang
on let's keep things really simple how
could I make things really simple I
still can't move my nutty Queen takes
Knight is threatened I think I just want
to take the bishop hmm that wouldn't be
good Queen takes Knight and then i'm
down the exchange crap what do i do I
drafting with my king here no no no then
there's like look takes King here Queen
check crap what do I do hmm just can't
be easy can it Queen here is that saving
stuff I gotta move quick oh this better
work ah man why can't it be like simpler
for a game one come on defend come on
night you know you want to defend I'm
still trying to get warmed up to my
mouse you know you know how about that I
don't know what I want oh no no no this
is working out now cuz the bishop I'm
ready to take this or am I oh oh wait a
second oh I would have had just what
takes rock miscalculations everywhere
man I could have taken the bishop of
Queen takes Knight I take the rook that
would have been easier okay but maybe
this is better if crook takes now King
takes the Queen can't make use of g5
important detail the queen is very
annoying here isn't she
ah maybe this was just a better mood
then grabbing the bishop like I was
thinking Queen takes f6 Queen takes rook
what is my opponent uh chillin on here I
take what oh they resigned alright they
didn't they didn't uh they didn't test
out my mouse or anything it's nice all
right good game um let me back up here
let's see about that one and I'm gonna
flip it and look from your perspective
here I guess it was a winning
continuation it was still a little bit
scary for me all right drush maybe a
slightly better move is 83 not yet
committing this bishop okay um so I only
take after the bishop move we got a six
prepping be five mmm is a for the right
move to go with oh no I'm not up with
the theory at all I know what it does i
could recognize the weaknesses but i
don't know if this is theory is the a4
move really called for here otherwise
I'm expanding with b5 may be seen for or
something I'm Kyle wrong with it can't
be like losing or anything ah ah but
then again maybe it's tough for you to
do some stuff here I also wonder if
maybe before I get in b6 you could go
with a 5 maybe there's some lines where
you can like your nike get here but
maybe not if i'm able to post up here
with my night then I'm controlling be
six so I don't know about that mmm
is there an opportunity to take my night
and push d5 that's what I'm I'm
constantly looking for is this break
available here or here or here all these
different positions i don't think it's
really available this right here i think
is maybe a step in the wrong direction
because its wealth welcoming exchanges
I'm not so sure that's a good thing to
run with because I'm liking that once i
get to this position right here with
Queen before unless you have something
right away some attack against my king I
think I'm just better because of my
queen being very active so i don't know
i'm struggling to even suggest something
and that's a that's typical when you
have a good game going on here it's it's
tough to find like significant
improvements I don't know maybe
something instead of that night night
moved to g4 what else can you be doing
really don't know queen queen bee three
maybe I don't know that seems even a
little bit weird like maybe I have night
moves and then hitting the bishop in my
Queens hitting the pond tough game i
don't know i'm sorry i'm not able to
really suggest more i'm just i'm not
sure the a4 move maybe oh wait a second
maybe maybe you could do this instead of
84 i wonder if you could do like just 83
okay yes i get the b5 move in but you
tuck your Bishop back i don't have the
pivot square and b4 and you're still in
a position to maybe get in this d5 maybe
that's an improvement coming tracking
back here to a silly pawn move but i
think it's a key difference between a3
and a4 there anyhow it's it's worth
considering worth a closer look without
a doubt ok good game as usual ok my
opponent is saying a4 is theory so there
you go
okay so all right I don't know I don't
know then I don't I'm still lost how can
you would take advantage of the black
position of control over d5 what other
direction can might be going I'm not
really seeing it okay sorry sorry I
can't offer more okay let me close out